TVO's Megyn Kelly's NBC News show is
reportedly in jeopardy of being
cancelled following her controversial
blackface comments yesterday yesterday
Kelly told her viewers she was sorry on
Tuesday
Kelly questioned why wearing black faced
Halloween costumes was offensive
several of Kelly's NBC colleagues
sharply criticized her remarks CBS this
morning Saturday co-host Michelle Miller
is here with the backlash Michelle good
morning good morning megyn kelly today
has suffered from poor ratings since its
launch last September and has had its
share of controversies but Kelly's
latest comments have rankled others
inside NBC News and it seems like this
may end up being the final straw I want
to begin with two words I'm sorry just
one day after defending the use of
blackface on air NBC News host megyn
kelly reverse course I learned that
given the history of blackface being
used in awful ways by racists in this
country it is not okay for that to be
part of any costume her audience gave
her a standing ovation a stark contrast
from the response she received after her
divisive comments Tuesday you do get in
trouble if you are a white person who
puts on Halloween or a black person who
puts on white face Halloween like I was
a kid that was okay as long as you were
dressing up as like a character the
backlash from prominent figures at NBC
News was Swift she owes a bigger apology
to folks of color around the country
chairman Andy lack also condemned her
comments saying there is no place on our
air or in this workplace for them very
unfortunate megyn kelly has faced
criticism in the past for controversial
comments on Jesus and Santa Claus as a
Fox News host in 2013 and by the way for
all you kids watching at home
Santa just is white Jesus it was a white
man too
this is a disaster scenario for megyn
kelly Matt Bellamy is the editorial
director of The Hollywood Reporter she's
hiring an attorney to protect her rights
in this scenario and my sources say she
believes that the way that NBC is
handling her is inappropriate I would
think that this relationship is over
and megyn kelly will leave NBC News
entirely Melanie also says megyn kelly
has split from her talent agency CAA but
it's unclear whether Kelly or the agency
made that decision sources tell The
Hollywood Reporter several guests
including the cast of house of cards
have already cancelled appearances on
her show next week
yeah and NBC says she will not be
appearing on her show today or tomorrow
I think Andy lacks some did it well it's
just the whole thing is just unfortunate
it's surprising to hear that she's just
now learning the history of a black face
but I think it's a lesson well learned
for everybody that might not have known
what most people have known for years
and years and years it's not that it's
her ignorance that is on stage here it's
that you have to really be open to
hearing people out over why something
may or may not be offensive and I think
this is Ellis trading and then she has
apologized
yes she has please not lose sight of
that she did apologize Michele thank you
thank you